[Música]
contras
virgilio escribió hace mucho tiempo en
la eneida amor vincit omnia el amor todo
lo vence el amor todo lo puede
esa es una expresión que me acompaña
todos los días desde que me levanto
hasta que me acuesto dirigieron la
escribió con una mayúscula porque
entendía que el amor no existe
existen las cosas que podemos ver las
cosas que son atemporales pero el amor
es porque es esencia es principio es fin
absolutamente de todo lo que hacemos
hoy les quiero invitar a que hagan un
pequeño ejercicio como si estuviéramos
en un aula
quiero que se imaginen que mentalmente
me dibujen el amor
supongo que se ahorita ya lo imaginaron
debido a ser un corazón rojo
o quizás la mayoría una vez hice esa
pregunta en frente de unos pequeños
niños en un salón de clase estábamos
viendo las emociones los feelings y les
pedí que por favor me dibujaron el amor
y se empezaron a levantar y unos me
dibujaron el corazón rojo pero de
repente otros empezaron a llevarme
corazones verdes corazones amarillos
corazones naranjas me acuerdo que yo les
pregunté elige porque de este color y
cada uno tuvo una explicación de por qué
el color
eso me enseñó que la gente que contrasta
que vive sin grises entiende que la vida
es multicolor y después me di cuenta que
conforme van creciendo muchas voces se
van apagando esas ilusiones es esencia
que cada uno porta se va silenciando
porque a veces mal interpretamos ese
término amor lo podemos confundir con
necesidad lo podemos confundir con vacío
lo podemos confundir con obsesión lo
podemos confundir con pasión y me
gustaría aclararles que la pasión si es
un sentimiento y como todos llega y se
puede ir te puedo apasionar hay una cosa
y después te puede apasionar otra cosa
pero el amor siempre está presente hoy
me gustaría recordarles que nunca es
bueno confundir el esfuerzo que haces
para mantener el amor con el amor porque
éste tiene características reales
características que transforman porque
vivir les del amor es la esencia más
alta que cada uno podemos
el amor transforma la existencia de cada
ser humano a lo largo de esta vida de
este viaje
he descubierto que el amor es libertad
me ha tocado ver muchos seres humanos
que son prisioneros de juicios de
complejos de prejuicios de cadenas e
incluso de ideas erróneas me ha tocado
ver alumnos que les han enseñado y les
dicen te pego y me duele más que a ti lo
hago porque te quiero y crecen con
conceptos erróneos del amor crecen con
ideas erróneas recuerdo a marta una
señora que me dio mi primer lección de
vida en ese sentido vivir desde el amor
ella tardó mucho de embarazarse ella lo
buscó y ya grande ese embarazo cuando su
hijo cumplió los 18 años en paz descanse
éste fue privado de la vida en manos de
otro muchacho que había precisamente
generado ideas erróneas del amor que
estaba lleno de cicatrices que estaba
lleno de esas cadenas era preso de eso
que dentro de él están
recuerdo que bueno este evento colapsó
muchas personas y todos se exigían que
el muchacho que perpetró el crimen pues
todo el peso de la ley la justicia sin
embargo ella recuerdo que fue a ver
donde lo tenían detenido y le dijo tú me
quitaste un hijo ahora tú vas a ser mi
hijo
y le dio a este muchacho la oportunidad
de una nueva vida lo liberó de lo que él
mismo sin darse cuenta en algún punto se
condenó y actualmente ese muchacho se
dedica a apoyar a otros adolescentes y a
otras personas que como él en algún
punto se le olvidó este concepto se le
olvidó que el amor es esencia de vida
la primera característica que tiene el
amor es libertad el amor es el aroma de
la libertad cuando ofreces libertad a
las personas cuando lo ofreces el regalo
de ser quien es ellos son puedes
descubrir grandes cosas y ese mi boca la
siguiente característica del amor el
amor es paciencia
vivimos actualmente este mundo donde
queremos todo perfecto de alguna manera
donde queremos todo rápido donde no hay
tiempo para hacer absolutamente nada
pero sin embargo si vemos el cosmos y
volvamos a ver la naturaleza ésta nos
enseña la lección más grande que es la
paciencia porque si yo plantó una
semilla esta va a crecer cuando tiene
que ser no cuando yo quiera y lo va a
hacer como un acto espontáneo como un
acto natural nadie le dice a una planta
a una flor crece eso es ilógico lo hace
como un acto natural espontáneo como
cualquier cosa que los seres humanos
podemos hacer esa paciencia cuando la
tienes cuando vives desde el amor cuando
no juzgas le permites a las demás
personas que esa semilla que está por
dentro dé frutos porque cuando te pones
los lentes sobres con los ojos del
juicio del miedo de la imposición estás
bloqueando un proceso que es natural
todo acto humano que realizamos debe ser
un acto espontáneo es como el hecho que
le digas a alguien a mamá eso es
irracional eso no se puede se da en una
forma natural
lo que me lleva a la tercera
característica que he aprendido en este
viaje de vida del amor el amor es
comprensión y la comprensión es de las
cosas más extraordinarias que cualquiera
puede ofrecer a otro ser humano
como profesor en español las palabras
cuando les agregamos el sufijo a las
volvemos contrarias dicción es nuestra
capacidad de comunicar es nuestra
capacidad de hablar de decir quiénes
somos cuándo adicción le agregamos ese
sufijo se convierte en adicción
he visto muchas personas en mi vida que
eran presas de estas adicciones ya sea
el alcoholismo ya sea la drogadicción y
hace muchos y cientos de adicciones y
que lograron liberarse
cuando les ofreces un espacio para
expresar lo que son
cuando les permites escuchar cuando no
los juzgues cuando los comprendes
trabajo en salones y me doy cuenta que
muchos de esos maestros de vida como les
llamo que tengo enfrente su gente más
cercana su familia no los escucha
van a la escuela trabajan pero cuando
les preguntas algo cuando les das las
libertades que se expresen te dicen
grandes verdades y encuentras grandes
cosas ahí me ha tocado tener alumnos que
le digo le gusta esto que está
estudiando
pues no
de acuerdo con aves decís este ejercicio
a ver si el dinero no fuera una
imposición si lo que los demás se han
dicho no fuera una imposición estarían
estudiando esto que ahorita hacen de 30
alumnos 25 me contestaron que no
eso me enseñó que estamos formando
futuros seres humanos que entienden que
el dinero es más importante que escuchar
su corazón que escuchar aquello que les
da libertad que llegaron para hacer y
entonces si lo piensan de una forma eso
es un poco irracional porque entonces
saber voy a trabajar en algo que no me
agrada que no me llena que no amo para
generar dinero y para seguir viviendo de
una forma que no me gusta eso es algo
ilógico todo ser humano y toda vida
tiene un propósito y nadie mejor que
cada uno sabe qué es aquello que hace
que tu corazón lata
el amor tiene otra característica el
amor es generosidad el amor es dar sin
esperar absolutamente nada a cambio he
visto los efectos de todas las personas
que han rodeado mi camino de vida que
cuando dan algo sin esperar al cambio
como siempre han en otro ser humano yo
creo que mi lección de generosidad más
fuerte vino también y una alumna que
estaba en unas condiciones precarias
pero ese día se enteró que había sido mi
cumpleaños porque otros profesores haití
ser felicidad es saber cuando festejamos
recuerdo que esta niña me lleva un
platito con dos tacos dorados créanme
que son los peores tacos dorados que
viste en mi vida porque como les aclaré
sus condiciones de ese lugar eran
precarias la lechuga estaba verde y
quemada y lo que traía arriba dije será
queso unicel
el punto fue que cuando me quedé sentado
me los de me dice gracias teacher lo
quiero mucho y me da un abrazo volteo la
veo y ya sólo tenía un taco
me dio lo mejor que tenía en ese momento
sin conocerme porque es volver a su
profesor
posiblemente si alguien me preguntara
podría definir la generosidad de
distintas fuentes
pero vivirla y sentirla y lo que esa
niño transforma en mi existencia
fue infinito
porque entonces gracias a esa acción que
vino de una pequeña me permite hacer
muchas cosas y cuando alguien me
preguntaba y me decía por qué haces eso
perteneces a alguna asociación
religiosos estás buscando algo no porque
puedo
porque posiblemente no pueda cambiar
todo el mundo pero cuando cambias una
vida cuando tocas una vida
automáticamente estás cambiando mucho si
se hace una cadenita
lo cual me lleva a comentarles la
siguiente característica que he
experimentado del amor y esa
característica que tiene es que el amor
es bondad yo creo que todos conocemos
aquí como les llamo a héroes invisibles
personas que nunca va a saber a lo mejor
en una revista en una portada pero que
aquello que les tocó hacer y que le
quieran hacer en la vida lo hacen con
amor esas personas siempre he dicho que
construyen catedrales
dijo un gran escritor que ya nadie va a
construir catedrales porque nadie estaba
dispuesto a pasar su vida sin que
alguien se lo reconociera porque yo los
invito a que si ustedes van a visitar
cualquier catedral del mundo no van a
ver específicamente el nombre de alguien
que la construyó porque fueron muchas
manos que estuvieron y muchos se
llevaron más de 100 años
y estas personas que les digo esos seres
que seguramente ustedes conocen que en
su vida los han acompañado
les han formado y les han permitido
estar donde están
yo lo experimentado con mis alumnos y
con esa cadena de que llegan y traen los
sueños y me voy de intercambio voy a
trabajar
pero no sería posible sin esa mano que
le dice aquí está tu lonche aquí está tu
dinero para el camión y que lo hacen con
amor sin buscar la gloria y que todos me
vean sino simplemente el hecho porque
disfruto lo que hago desde el corazón
eso enseña entonces que el amor tiene
una característica muy poderosa el amor
es esperanza todo ser humano es
esperanza en sí mismo recuerdo una vez
que platiqué con un amigo que estaba muy
triste y que no quería salir no después
te veo no que esto pero a veces es bueno
ser terco y lo convencí fuimos por un
café platicando se soltó y me empezó a
contar un montón de cosas que sentía
recuerdo que cuando nos despedimos en
ese momento únicamente le dio un abrazo
porque ni un consejo le di solo deje que
se expresara que fuera el que dijera que
sacara eso que llevaba por dentro esa
noche me mandó un mensaje de texto y me
dice muchas gracias por escucharme álex
se había tomado la decisión de acabar
con mi vida pero gracias por escucharme
porque descubrí que todavía hay muchas
cosas por vivir
este ejemplo me enseña el poder que
tienes tú cuando le permites a alguien
escuchar y te conviertes en la esperanza
el amor deja de ser un simple concepto y
se convierte en una realidad porque
entonces el amor descubres que no es un
sentimiento es una práctica se vive
desde el amor y descubres entonces que
no es el exterior sino tu interior lo
que va a comandar cada uno de tus actos
y finalmente la característica más alta
que pude ver del amor en mi vida es el
servicio
he visto que no importa lo que te
dediques no importa que seas profesor
que seas atleta que seas actor que seas
médico si desempeña su labor con amor
estás dejando una huella en cada ser
humano está rescatando vidas porque les
estás permitiendo ser
o los invito a que en su círculo más
cercano
amén escuche pregúntense cuando fue la
última vez que le permite a alguien
expresar quién era que le permite hacer
hazlo y vas a ver el efecto y vas a
descubrir muchas cosas porque vivir
desde el amor es lo más sabio y es lo
más extraordinario que puedes hacer no
esperen en su vida las grandes epifanías
las grandes situaciones las grandes
cosas que van a pasar no desde dónde
estás de pie hazlo y vas a salvar más
vidas de las que te imaginas
finalmente
como dijo virgilio amor vincit omnia
creo que el amor todo lo vence todo lo
puede y todo lo conquista creo
firmemente que el amor no existe porque
el amor es y creo firmemente que cuando
se vive desde ahí puedes transformar
cualquier existencia humana y estás
logrando hacer algo extraordinario por
este mundo
cuando logramos hacer esto y cuando
vives desde ahí y rescatas una vida
entonces tu misión está lograda las
personas más bellas y maravillosas que
me encontraba en mi vida son aquellas
que han conocido la lucha el dolor la
derrota la riqueza la pobreza y de
alguna forma han encontrado la forma
para salir de ahí estas personas generan
una compasión y una apreciación por el
amor y la vida diferente la gente bella
no surge de la nada
recuerdan su amor vincit omnia vivan
desde el amor
denle paso al amor porque al fin y al
cabo es lo único que se van a llevar
seguramente cuando partan de esta
experiencia humana muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]